attention will get you everything you
want you want to sell a course attention
you want to sell a t-shirt attention you
want to be the mayor of this town
attention you want to raise some money
for your non-profit because you're
passionate about it attention you want
to be an actor attention attention let
me tell you a story
when I was a young man marketing for my
dad's liquor store and wine store if you
wanted to get people to know about you
you had to pay
I had to pay a newspaper to put an
advertising in the newspaper I had to
pay
a cable company to run my TV commercial
I had to pay
for a billboard to show my sign I had to
pay
the marketing Direct Mail company to
make a flyer and send it into your
mailbox so you would see it I had to pay
today
the attention of the world
lives
in here
the things that dominate here is gaming
and entertainment and social networks
people here complain
that they're not getting a lot of views
on their videos on Instagram or Tick
Tock or these platforms but they have
forgotten that it's free let me say this
nice and slow today
if you were to advertise on social
networks the cost of showing up
not making it but showing up
is free
this is crazy
Google which I used a lot Google AdWords
how many people here do Google AdWords
pretty aggressively for your business
a little higher I just want to get a
sense
a lot of you
Google charges you money when somebody
clicks
not everybody converts you try to figure
out if the amount you pay do enough
people convert that it's worth your
money but it still costs you money
The Social Network Revolution is insane
it is free
to build brand
most people in this room most people in
Brazil most people in South America most
people in the world
do not produce enough content for how
big the opportunity is for free
attention
that is the biggest elephant in this
room today
it is a wow
it's a wow because it's [__] free and
yet people will complain and say oh
Instagram Shadow Banned Me Nobody Shadow
ban you you just suck at social media
and so I come here on this long flight
to pound your attention
attention will get you everything you
want you want to sell a course attention
you want to sell a t-shirt attention you
want to be the mayor of this town
attention you want to raise some money
for your non-profit because you're
passionate about it attention you want
to be an actor attention attention it is
the only asset that everyone in here
must Chase to produce what they want
being unemotional about where the
attention is is very important
too many of you have demonized platforms
out of
your subjective opinion
a bad experience
and we must get over that hump once you
get over the hump once you sit in this
room and understand that everything you
want to happen is about building brand
and sales in social networks
then you start having to get good at it
right it's like health and fitness I can
tell you the way to get healthier is to
eat better and go to the gym and once
you understand that that there's no
magic pill then you can do it the
problem is there's a good way to work
out and there's a bad way there's a good
way to eat clean and healthy and there's
an okay way where you get tricked if
it's really healthy or not the thing I
spend all my time on today in my career
even though I've been in this for a long
time on the flight here with Dustin with
raghav all I was talking about was the
strategies on the creative that we're
posting in Social is the thumbnail good
most people hear when they post on
social media post because they're
following a trend that they think will
do well or some [__] they want to say
but they give no thought and this is the
most important line maybe of the entire
talk so I want everyone to pay attention
they give no thought to the science
of the art
no thought of the math around the art to
build brands
[Music]
foreign